all right well last night in Ohio voters
shot down a GOP measure you probably
heard about it that would have made it
more difficult to add abortion rights to
the state's Constitution the subsequent
spiking of the football of course on the
left well was predictable
it has been a potent potent uh political
punch in the gut against Republicans
who've been trying to take away women's
rights coming out of Dobbs Republicans
are simply out of step with the majority
of Voters what we saw last night is such
an important Victory as we head to a
critical vote which should be made by
the people
this is all they have to run on remember
that wasn't Joe Scarborough pro-life at
one point I guess I forgot that of
course the decisions should be made by
the people that was the whole point of
overturning Roe versus Wade that's what
democracy is in fact a new CNN poll
found that 66 percent of those are happy
with the course decision to overturn Roe
that they want pro-life politicians to
leave abortion decisions up to each
state and that's what we see happening
across the country look I don't agree
with Ohio's decision here and I'll I'm
never going to apologize for being
pro-life but we wanted the issue to go
to the voters take it out of the hands
of unelected judges and justices and
give it to the people and let the
politicians try to persuade voters one
way or another
but running away from this issue as a
republican it's not going to work
becoming like what pro-abortion well
that you know voters would consider that
to be evil uh so we have to fight it out
state by state and we should ignore the
voices of those who think the Dobbs
decision was wrongly decided and that
abortion should be enshrined in the
Constitution our framers never would
have considered it the left understands
that some principles are more important
than short-term election results they
know that their views offend Christians
and other social conservatives across
the country and they know that that
actually costs them elections all across
the country
issues like trans rights and so forth
but they don't care they stick to their
guns and they try to change Minds on
their side and sometimes they succeed
for years they defended the left-wing
decisions of the Warren Court even as
Nixon and Reagan rode those decisions to
Victory
and of course they push to impose gay
marriage on every state even when the
voters were against it
so if they can fight for their beliefs
and they can fight for their principles
we can and we should fight for ours
and one more thing
it's a real mistake to think that the
GOP
Could Have Lied forever to the voters
about its views on abortion that it
could claim to be pro-life but always
keep Roe in place
that's the type of cynical thinking that
caused GOP voters to turn on the bushes
then of course turn on the cheneys and
pick Trump instead
overturning Roe versus Wade is the
greatest accomplishment the conservative
movement has had since the end of the
Cold War we should be proud of it and
build on it not run away from it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else